Britany is with us in Johnson City
Tennessee
hi Brittany how are you I'm good how are
you days better than I deserve what's up
okay so my husband and I got s to you
for our wedding and we didn't get to the
insurance part before we purchased our
loss insurance and we got permanent in
part terms and of course we watched the
insurance for it last night and we just
got the life insurance about a week ago
so I texted our financial advisor and
said we immediately wanted to get rid of
the term or sorry the permanent and just
have terms and he said Dave Ramsey is
talking about whole life permanent
insurance not portfolio based permanent
insurance which is what you have so is
it still bad should we still just get
the term yeah apparently he doesn't know
much about Dave Ramsey okay Dave Ramsey
does not ever invest I was real clear in
the lesson you heard me yeah when you I
never tell you under any circumstances
to use life insurance as an investment
vehicle 100% of the time it sucks so
would you say because what we told him
we wanted to do is I would say you know
a new financial advisor okay that's what
I would tell you you don't have a
financial advisor you have a life
insurance salesman okay
just selling you insurance so what we
were thinking we should do is switch to
four hundred thousand justice term each
and then the money we were because it
was like three hundred dollars a month
which all the watch and just go ahead
and open up our Ross Ross our IRA and
start getting money into that mutual
funds okay
that's exactly what you learned in class
wasn't yeah so you already knew what
Dave Ramsey said yeah which tells me one
of the things either this guy's a liar
or he's ignorant right yeah he's a
family friend isn't he actually one of
our friends just apparently gave him our
number because they use
for it as well yeah you know okay so I
don't know which it is I mean I don't
know I don't know but but I do know that
I have never in my life told someone to
buy life insurance as an investment
under any brand heading name or
description ever right and the last
thing is on our turn policy on your
class you said you know twenty years
thirty years whatever was fun and our
term policy was until we were 80 with
him okay why don't you jump on Zander
insurance comm and see what you can buy
a 20-year level term policy form I think
it's gonna blow your mind how much this
guy's overcharged you for everything he
sold you okay okay and you're probably
gonna end up just canceling everything
with him so this kind of really needs a
good firing okay that sounds like what
we're gonna do in the end of this week
all right thank you for calling in and
when you compare the prices you'll see
what I'm talking about and you
understood the lesson when we were
talking about using life insurance as an
investment vehicle and the reason is
folks for those of you that haven't seen
the Financial Peace University lesson or
never for some reason heard a Ramsey
talk about this okay someone else ever
brings this up because it does come up
periodically the people who sell
investment based or whole life or
permanent life or portfolio or universal
or anything where there's an investment
going into insurance are not happy with
me they don't like me and so they
generally try to ignore me or lie about
me or something else because I pretty
much cost them all a bunch of business
because they sell crap crap in a bag
that's what it is okay it's pretty
simple so here's the thing when you use
life insurance as an investment vehicle
a you get a bad rate of return
regardless of what they quote you after
they take all of their fees
usually in the first two years is 100%
sometimes up to four years is 100% of
what should have gone to the investment
goes out in fees even after that you're
gonna make three four five percent on
your money and you should have been in a
good mutual fund making ten eleven
twelve percent on your money and that's
where you should be when you die with
cash value permanent portfolio Universal
indexed universal life insurance they
pay only the face amount of the policy
not the extra money that you put into
the investment that money is gone so you
have a savings account that for the
first several years they keep all your
money after that they give you a battery
of return and when you die they keep it
all this is a bad savings account it's a
bad investment program the pay the the
life insurance products that give you
the opportunity to pay twenty times more
than you would pay for term insurance in
order that you create an investment
inside of the policy are basically the
payday lender the middle class they're
crap and that's what Dave Ramsey has
always said for 25 years here on the air
upset it and for 25 years it's all I
have owned myself I have never owned
while this show was operating any kind
of whole life or investment based life
insurance of any kind ever now I did get
a horrible Northwestern Mutual whole
life grotesque old school one of the
worst of the worst of the whole lives
when I was in my early 20s and it was
the same way Brittany it was a guy my
wife knew from college came around
selling right after we got married and
we bought this crap from him I had it
for about nine months until I finally
sat down with some guys who unpacked the
numbers for me and I about
kicked my own butt when I saw how bad it
was and got rid of it and since then I
have never owned it and since then I've
never told anyone to buy anything other
than 15 to 20 year term life insurance
about 10 to 12 times your income on you
the best way to buy life insurance is
through a broker that shops several
companies the best way to buy insurance
of any kind is there a broker that shops
several companies and gets you the best
possible deal whether it's your car
insurance your homeowners insurance your
long-term care insurance your life
insurance your insurance of any kind let
a broker shop among several companies
and get you the best kinds of deal and
that's why we've endorsed for about
twenty years
xander insurance jeff sander has become
a personal friend of mine during that
time and I buy my personal life
insurance from Zander and I don't own
Zander insurance I don't own any of it
that's the other lie that's always told
about me I would I would have a whole
lot more money if I did own Zander
insurance because Jeff has done rather
well due to the Dave Ramsey endorsement
but the reason he done well is he's got
a very very good system for getting you
the best possible price on term life
insurance and it takes about like 13
seconds and they don't sell your name to
a list of people when you go on there
either so that's why I've endorsed them
it's real simple it takes care of you
guys you the listener and you need to
get term life insurance it doesn't cost
that much so just jump in there and do
it so Brittany thank you for calling in
with that question and giving me the
opportunity to clarify on that yet again
yet again yet again yet again yet again
yes you need life insurance oh by the
way a broker you know like even with
your car insurance
jump on the e oh wait they could get
with the ELP use the endorse local
providers for your what we call PNC
Property and Casualty that's your car
and your homeowners insurance you can
shop most people save three to eight
hundred dollars a year on their car and
homeowners when you shop at among
several companies instead of using what
we call
captive agent in the business a captive
agent can self of one company like a
State Farm agent or a nationwide in
agent or Peyton Manning and Brad Paisley
can sing to you agent was it nationwide
that's nationwide in it yeah but and
they're both good guys I like both of
them there's nothing to do with that but
you're paying for those guys when you
when you use that insurance it's it's
built-in and neither one of those guys
work cheap I'll just tell you this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]